[Music]
now that Arizona's passed a bill that
lets business owners like me refuse
service to homosexuals based on my own
religious beliefs I can finally breathe
a sigh of relief and so can you knowing
you can shop in a completely homosexual
free environment in my store
Jack dundies all gay adult Emporium
you'll find Scottsdale's find a
selection of gay adult paraphernalia
including all the latest and hottest
video titles like the wolf a blank
screen and 12 inches a slave what you
won't find in my store are homosexuals
just good god-fearing heterosexual men
interested in hardcore gay pornography
just installed a few of these private
closets where you and another non gay
fella can hang out and relax in
15-minute intervals with every purchase
you make you'll get one of these nifty
multicolored and American flags I found
in a storage closet put it in your truck
to show everyone your pride and
arizona's legislative system so come on
down the jacked undies all gay adult
emporium and remember our tag line we're
here we refuse to serve you if you're
queer get used to it Jeff junkies all
gay
behind the heterosexuals only lesbian
bookstore just look for the big pink
side unless you're gay